[Music]
in thinking caps news committed by black
or white white white black both because
I like Klondike bars I just had black to
balance it out I said white to represent
a factory claims its using helmet to
scan workers brainwaves to increase
productivity what I don't understand a
word that just [ __ ] happen right now
yeah is using helmets to scan workers
brainwaves to increase productivity
that's what you deserve
that's next level how happen that's you
can't you just take the helmet off if
you're [ __ ] around nobody it
stimulates your brain so they mate they
might feel better it's not for
stimulation it's monitoring scan right
it's for like data collecting yeah it's
like hey you better be do you ain't
collecting my data I mean what is what
are they collecting is like how you feel
when you're doing boring [ __ ] work
they they read workers emotions and they
use artificial intelligent intelligence
algorithms to detect emotional spikes
such as depression anxiety or British so
if I just got off the phone and had a
fight with my fight or whatever and I'm
in the assembly line and then that put
the helmet on and then I'm like mad then
somebody comes down says Joe do we need
to talk like yes we do [ __ ] yeah
and then you're feeling they're resolved
in then you go back to work happy
alright so I would trick the system if I
don't want to [ __ ] work I would
always have some kind of [ __ ] so
that I could just go in the counsellors
room and we could talk for hours with
some tea and [ __ ] and I won't even work
I'll just collect the checks I am so yep
Wow how do you do it I know how to scam
[ __ ]
yeah so can you guys guess where this is
to China Japan America just kidding it
can't be China
it can't be China they can't do you have
a [ __ ] they let their workers [ __ ]
keep working until they die what I care
about is putting up more suicide that's
alright for the product is this unlike
some Nordic country it's gotta be
European no Joe got it right it was
Jenna all and I retracted that [ __ ]
because I was like Chinese people don't
give a [ __ ] about their [ __ ] employee
Chinese people love collecting data on
their citizens right don't be like don't
they just monitor literally everything
they do I guess I don't know the Brits
do that right yeah what they're they
have like more cameras than people there
oh yeah I heard that yeah I just I just
didn't know China I can't give a damn
about their employees yeah and I just
thought like if they wanted their
employees at work harder they just
yelled out or more or like you have a
weapon smack did you hear about that
[ __ ] with the Chinese people in the
garlic and [ __ ] no in the garlic the
garlic so like they this is whole back
story I'm going to talk about it but
basically they use like slave labor for
even if you get those like peeled garlic
and it comes from like basically one
company and they're using a slave or
prison labor to peel garlic and they
can't give unless they finished like 20
pounds of garlic in that day and there
was like video clips of like this guy he
thought he was eating the garlic heals
why are you letting that worker eat the
garlic oh he's not eating the garlic
he's peeling it because he has no more
nails so he's peeling the garlic was
teeth oh but I love peeled garlic this
is the guy that buys it all the time and
he never uses it is so handy you could
just buy the ones that you know the
supermarket pill oh it's a [ __ ] to peel
and it gets on your fingernails and [ __ ]
and smells like you take the garlic and
you go and it peels off like that what
yeah there's another hack to if you get
to mixing bowls and you [ __ ] shred it
up and you shake it like sure giving
that to the worker or you get a garlic
please do that they come probably get
Chinese prisoners oh yeah that's what
I've been doing anything they're pretty
cheap on Amazon
oh no Alibaba we got buying yeah I guess
that's where it come from yeah yeah but
it's pretty bad and I guess like there's
just whole there was this whole thing
that went out when they would like
because it's like for an American
company and American products can't be
used to prison in slave labor so
this whole thing about pole yeah our
garlic comes from China yeah a lot of it
this is crazy how produce comes from
halfway across the world and we it's
like still fresh that's pretty insane
does that happen yeah how does that
happen you have like garlic how here but
then there's just the abundance and how
cheap it is over there yes my boy it
takes three months to ship some [ __ ]
from China three months and it's still
fresh garlic yeah any no no well I mean
the average shipping is about you're
probably thinking free yeah I mean
they're not gonna overnight it and
there's what do they because it's so
much [ __ ] money the overnight garlic
or produce yeah because the things that
are overnight it over like are flown
over like fruits from Japan or whatever
they're [ __ ] expensive but like
pineapples from South America or
whatever all those things are just like
sent they time them out go right the
ones that ripen over time they send it
over there and then pull up all the
freight scheduling you know let's get
the freight scheduling up yeah let's get
all the customs you should be talking
about Freight stuff because you don't
have a freight expert person there I
used to work in logistics did I used to
schedule [ __ ] you tell us the freight
schedule go domestic only okay that
wasn't a form I learned a lot but yeah
so it's kind of a lot of people are
looking at this and saying damn like how
much further or Chinese people are gonna
take it like nothing surprises me about
China their concept of rights is
different than yeah humans are still
livestock - yeah oh my god how could
they treat humans this way well they
have like a billion people so there's
like a cockroach they don't care well
well according to this article here when
smartwatches were booming there was this
startup that was trying to make a
SmartWatch app that bosses could use to
track employees productivity and
apparently this one lazy this one lazy
like that it gives you warnings
something like that and then a geek wire
saw that Amazon had a patent for a smart
wristband to give to warehouse employees
that would
where the workers hands were and it
would send radio signals between the
wristband and the inventory so they
can't steal is it stealing or is it like
productivity he's pretty fast are they
moving uh stuff oh I would I would just
do this all day then near the inventory
yeah I just do this although yeah you
know like how did you only do two boxes
huh because I'm more about quality
betting about proficiency
I believe in peeling garlic I believe in
it
and I want to do it exactly right
exactly that's what all the artists do
in America apparently it's easier to
peel garlic it was soaked in water and
that's why their nails fall off because
their hands are always wrinkly and then
it just doesn't go back they need to
just use the two bowls technique because
healing one garlic at a time is pretty
bad that's how I felt like peeling
garlic when when I'm feeling garlic for
like a Nikki video or something like I
feel like a [ __ ] slave and I'm saying
Oh bro you've got a crush it and then
the husk just comes right off
no I were the [ __ ] pants and walk
away I fight nice you won't listen okay
I get the flu and I'll go garlic garlic
garlic yep
[ __ ] get everybody in the world I'm a
prisoner they can't fire me they can
only kill me she already took everything
from me what they got my fingernails
everything what else I gotta fight the
power [ __ ] they gotta put up more girls
I'll put a booger on that [ __ ] garlic
yes thank you do it I'm gonna
contaminate the [ __ ] out of that [ __ ]
meat and they start liking the garlic
more like a salty garlic going but
they're like being recorded to 24/7 like
surveillance instead of prison yeah
Jesus they have some [ __ ] here with the
chicken farms people were putting
diapers on the chicken farmers so they
don't waste time going to the lab
Amazon employees - we talked about we're
taking a dump in their truck and they
were wearing diapers - right they're
peeing in bought water bottles and
they're getting paid [ __ ] all right I'm
thinking like seven bucks an ounce or
something you know what though Amazon
you guys get my packages in so fast it's
so worth it but I get so pissed if I
don't if it says next day and I don't
get a next day you don't get it next day
I freak the [ __ ] out I know how you feel
it happens a lot I never had that [ __ ]
what happens a lot it happens all the
Fidesz next day to me it kind of next
day but the standard is two days right
and then this is one little button that
says you can get it next day for free -
free - why even dangle that a part of my
face that's what is this an idiot test
because I'm not an idiot I'll get it
tomorrow and then I sometimes don't get
it tomorrow I get [ __ ] pissed I'm
like on what their name was their badge
number and I want their [ __ ] job
crazy thing about Amazon is if you say
that I'm pretty sure they'll fire that
employee will you have it probably would
it so disposable for Amazon like they
they hate their employees they actually
hate that doesn't sound like a Chinese
company dude it's puzzles Chinese I
don't know I think exploiting employees
or it's like [ __ ] awesome but then
like I can't ever admit that it's all
it's only it's only awesome I don't want
to do it I like in and out you know
that's my concept like I don't want to
do it for any of my companies I because
I want other people to do it I benefit
from the service but then I could be
like I could play the high I could play
the higher ground like I'm like hey hey
look at look at our guys everyone's dog
getting pay like we're fun we're like a
family hey hey we're going to [ __ ]
Vegas so when I take you guys to Vegas
and [ __ ] like that you really appreciate
it because then you look at McDonald's
people and you're like [ __ ] they don't
get to go to Vegas so yeah that's a good
strategy
you're turning more expensive yep and
then like the kids in China that are
[ __ ] like making iPhones and [ __ ] and
then they feel like I can't even afford
what the [ __ ] of me I want to call the
Vegas yeah and then and then see and
then you guys feel even more like like
awesome and then but then and then and I
go to like these different places like
Amazon or whatever and I get all these
products really cheap and fast and [ __ ]
and I get the benefits but I don't have
to export to look out
be good while you use the slave labor in
the back exactly like it that's marks
like people that buy like all the Nike
and all that [ __ ] and then like you know
they want to talk [ __ ] about like other
businesses that everybody you talk [ __ ]
on child labor but they have an iPhone
we have an iPhone we have [ __ ] shoes
oh that's right everybody mm-hmm it's
like dude those cats are getting like 10
cents yeah by the way stuff made without
child labor [ __ ] sucks
[Music]